okay welcome to the ddps ddps seminar
everyone before we introduce our invited
speaker uh let's go over some rules and
Logistics uh first please mute yourself
during the talk unless you have
questions if you do have questions you
are welcome to unmute and um ask
otherwise please use chat room to post
your questions so that we can address
them in Q&A session at the end second
today's ddps seminar is open to external
audiences uh so no classifi discussion
is allowed and finally The Talk today
will be recorded and uploaded in our
YouTube channel that's about it now let
me introduce our uh speaker today it is
an honor to host uh soldad Viller who is
an assistant professor of Applied
Mathematics and statistics at jnes
Hopkins University she did her
undergraduate studies at uh univer
University un University the Republic
Uruguay and her PhD in mathematics at UT
Austin afterwards she held post-
doctoral position at UC Berkeley and New
York University in 2019 she was selected
as a rising star in computational and
data science her research is funded by
NSF onl Amazon and Simons Foundation
today uh so that we'll talk about uh the
passive symmetries of machine learning
which is a uh which will be very
interesting um so please enjoy and
expect a wonderful talk now without
further Ado let me pass the button to uh
sold that uh by asking one random
question as usual today's random
question is
um what is your
superpower um that the people um um
don't usually have can you pick one sh
with us
um well okay uh
so um so I'm I I think that's something
that unusual I don't know if it's a
superpower but something unusual for me
is that I'm from a small country in
South America which is urai and uh
that's um it it's interesting because I
think that you get a different life
experience than other people just
because you come from like a very
unusual place so people get very
surprised about it great thank you so
that you answered that well okay the
stage is
yours so uh okay so I'm going to talk
about the passive symmetries of machine
learning and uh what I heard uh about
the audience is that you're mostly
physicists uh working on machine
learning uh related uh stuff with with
physics so I don't really need to give
you the first slide about deep learning
and how it has done uh amazing things
changed the State ofthe art in several
domains this is just like an
introductory slide where I say well
people do amazing things with deep
learning image
classification uh playing go with
reinforcement learning and uh lately uh
the
there has been this developing and um
protein folding and my claim is that in
all these um models a a key Insight is
the use of symmetries and and also the
the use of overp parameterization so
first I'm going to discuss a little bit
about over parametrization and then the
main part of my talk is going to be
about symmetries and you know in in deep
learning we have these models that we
use to fit the data and they are very
overparameterized so we have maybe more
parameters than data points
significantly more parameters than data
points so we have a training set which
are like say images and their labels and
then we have a hypothesis class which is
what functions we use to fit the data so
for instance a convolutional neural
network with 42 layers or something like
that so we train the model and we obtain
uh one classifier for my image
classification Network which is like one
choice on the space of parameters uh one
choice on the space of waves so uh there
are many functions in this hypothesis
class of possible 42 layer neural
networks that can fit the data and even
they can fit the data perfectly so how
do you choose the right one uh how do
you make sure that your optimization
model or like your optimization
algorithm finds a function that
satisfies that that not only fits the
data but also it generalizes as well and
so there's a notion that people describe
in the machine Learning Community which
is called the inductive bias which is
like like what is the right assumptions
on your model and your optimization
algorithm so that the algorithms that
use that typically based on local
optimization converge to a good solution
namely that not only fits the data well
but also it generalizes to data that he
hasn't seen before for instance a test
set that may have the same distribution
as the training set or different one and
so and and there's a lot of interesting
work that had happened in the in the
past years regarding
overparameterization and how what
happens with using models that are very
overparameterized and so I have a few
like plots or like drawings from papers
in the literature so one that I like
very much and you probably know about it
is called understanding deep learning
requires reink and generalization and
this mod and this paper what shows is
that uh these overparameterized machine
learning models can fit
data any data that you want they can fit
until zero training error and they can
fit things like like noise they can fit
shuffle images with Shuffle p pixels
they can fit images with the wrong
labels and the fact that they can fit
anything uh tells you that well the fact
that they can do it why do they
generalize well and there is a the
there's some explanations that had to do
with like how fast they can they can be
trained and how well they generalize
after that there's uh there's other
works um one is the double descent work
and there's also the benign over feting
work that people by people there at
Berkeley that um that basically they
show that uh in over in
overparameterized modes you may get some
something that that can be explained as
they have better generalization the idea
is that in the classical statistical
regime uh you can fit
your uh you you you have a regime where
like you do under fitting a regime where
you do overfitting and then when the cap
capacity of the model is like uh um the
switch spot then you get the bias versus
optimal bias versus variance tradeoff
and that's the best model that you can
get like the lowest risk that you can
get for this model and what they show is
that if you do overparameterized models
in some settings you can go below Beyond
this this low bar uh and then get some
uh performance that is better than the
classical optimal with varable
parameterized models that's what it
means and that's what they call the
double descent and the benign
overfitting phenomena
but all all that to say that over
parameterized models have very weird um
performance and they have very
interesting mathematical properties and
just the design of the class of
functions and the optimization
algorithms that you're using is key for
having a model that performs well not
only on the training data but also in
the uh General test data or general
problem in
general and so uh there's the notion of
like the what is a correct or a good
inductive bias so how do you design
models so that they actually perform
well and so there's this recent book uh
by uh brunin br and collaborators that
is called geometric deep learning and
basically they claim that you can
exploit the structure of the input data
and of the input problem or and the
problem so that in the design of the
model so that they perform well like
that would give you a good inductive
bias and for example so for instance
convolution neur networks are designed
to work well with images and they have a
symmetry property which is that they are
translation equivalent
uh like if you seing a cat and you
translate this scat to the side then the
the fact that the CNN is translation
equan is a is a property that is useful
for image classification it kind of
encod the symmetries of the of the
actual problem and then for instance
record neural networks exploit some sort
of translation symmetries and then graph
neural networks exploit a symmetry that
has to do with symmetries that are um
like it doesn't it doesn't matter how
you express the graph as an AJC Matrix
and that's a passive Symmetry and I'm
going to explain in the next uh in the
next slide what are the passive
symmetries so uh in the physical
sciences uh you may or may not agree
with me and this is something that we
can discuss is that there exist two
types of
symmetries the active symmetries which
are the symmetries that come from The
observed regularities of the physics so
for instance syes that have to do with
conservation laws according to Nether
CRM so for instance the fact that if we
have conservation of energy that is
equivalent to say that there's a Time
translation symmetry in my dynamical
system or a conservation of momentum
which is uh equivalent to a a
translation Symmetry and a conservation
of angular momentum which can be
equivalent to a rotation symmetry so
those are the active symmetries
symmetries that are observe regularities
of the physics and they have to do with
modifications that we can do to the
world and observe that something is
preserved after we do this modification
and there's also the passive symmetries
that are symmetries that are not
symmetries of the world but are
symmetries that come from the fact that
when I express this physical object in
mathematical terms the choice of
expressing this object in math is not
unique I have to make a choice and then
if I do a transformation in my choice
then the the world doesn't change so
this transformation should be translated
ated into the physics into the obser
like into observations as well so for
instance if I express this object with
some set of coordinates and then I later
come back and I uh express the same
object with a different coordinate
coordinate system then the then the
observables should be consistent with
the change of coordinates that I express
and this includes like units
equivariance as well gauge invariances
and equivalences Etc so these are
symmetries that are just like they come
from the fact that there's not a unique
representation so the choice of the
representation induces some symmetries
that will show up and for instance say I
have a physical system and I make some
predictions based on everything
expressed in in every Mass expressed in
in kilograms if I change it to pounds
then the the data would change and the
prediction would change in a predi way
that's what it means uh like that's an
example of a classic uh passive Symmetry
and so the claim is that the machine
learning and data science methods should
be consistent with the symmetries in
order to be correct um so you you want
to parameterize the space of functions
so that they satisfy the symmetries of
the pum the active symmetries and the
passive symmetries and so an example
that is very is is very common in
machine learning right now and people
and this is a very active area of
research is the graph Nal networks or
graph
learning and the passive symmetry is a
very simple symmetry the idea is that
whatever learning function that I
express in a graph so I have my graph uh
and then I express this graph as an
adjacency Matrix and so this is one
possible adjacent Matrix the
representation of the graph as an adjac
Matrix is not not unique so I could
choose a different ordering of the of
the nodes in my adjacency Matrix and it
represents exactly the same graph so if
I take this this graph represented in
this way and I do a permutations of
these rows and these columns then I
obtain this graph uh this this
representation and it's just a different
way to represent the same object so uh
the function that I learned should be
consistent with respect to that change
so if it's like say if I'm just learning
a number say the length of the shortest
path then that number should be
invariant with respect to this
permutation so what I'm saying is that
uh F of Pi a pi transpose should be
equal to F of a that's an invariant
function for all Pi permutation so this
is the action of the permutation on the
input space and then the function is to
be invariant with respect to direction
or if I'm learning like a node embedding
uh so I'm learning some property for
each node then that node embedding
should be equivalent with respect to
this permutation action meaning that if
I permute the rows and The Columns of my
Matrix then the embedding needs to be
permuted as well and this is an
equivalent so the same group acts in the
input and in the output they don't
necessarily act on the same way but it's
just like it acts it's
yeah as so the question is how can we
efficiently parameterize the space of
invar equarian functions with respect to
permutations and this is what people do
in in graph neur networks or graph
learning and so there many interesting
research questions in graph learning
that have to do with like how to
parameterize the functions that on
graphs they equivalent so the typical
way of doing this is by implementing it
in a form of message passing so because
if you if you write like if message
passing is just like you learn a
function which is a message function
that each no send to their neighbors and
then there's another function which is
the aggregation function that each node
like Aggregates the message from their
neighbors and that is a very simple way
to express something that does not
depend on the representation of the
graph is a matrix so it's it's
equivalent just by definition it's just
like you need to know who your neighbors
are and that's it so this fun this is
like the classical way of doing graph
unit
networks and and the but then there is
like a very interesting area of research
that says like actually if you just
implement this these message passing
networks uh there are many functions
that cannot be expressed by them even
though they're equivalent with respect
to permutations or invariant and the
reason is because um like this this
action by the permutations is connected
with the graph isomorphism problem and
the graph isomorphism problem is not an
easy problem so so uh you may like just
just the complexity of this class of
functions is not sufficient to separate
nonisomorphic graphs certain knowing
isomorphic graphs so there's like a lot
of work uh trying to understand what
functions one can express with these
models or how you can modify these
models so that they can express more
functions and then some functions like
for instance classical message passing
your networks and not able to compute
trivial trivial functions like the
number of triangles in a graph and so
like you have to think a littleit a
little bit more and there's like many
interesting Works in this Cas um yeah
and and so and other questions that
people have studied are the stability of
the graph M networks how do you how can
you evaluate the transferability so say
what happens if I train a graph in a
network on a graphs that have 100 notes
and then evaluate them in graphs that
have a thousand notes can how can we say
that what this graphing network is doing
is consistent and then there's a lot of
work on like the evaluation of the
performance of graph and networks in
benchmarks which are being developed and
also in in theoretical models like
random graph
models but that's uh that so that's kind
of like a connection between like some
passive Symmetry and or some Symmetry
and then a model that relies on the
symmetry which is graph networks and a
lot of mathematic interesting
mathematical problems come from the
actual symmetry of these models and
there's that's just graph networks and
this is a an big part of my research but
I'm not going to focus on it on on this
talk I we we can talk about it offline
if you want uh or or maybe if you have
any questions I'm happy to answer them
that now but I'm just going to so the
idea for my talk today was to describe
other symmetrics that have to do with
scientific machine
learning any question okay so so
equivalent machine learning has to do
with um and the understanding of the
symmetries that go into the machine
learning models and the applications
include uh like dynamical system systems
fluid dynamics graphs I just mentioned
it particle systems in particular for
instance the the protein folding Alpha
fold uses equivalent Transformers in
part of the architecture so it it really
shows up in in many uh scientific
applications and just it's not just
graphs it goes beyond that so I'm going
to explain other ways that um symmetries
go to the definition of the machine
learning models and how to implement
them and and how to evaluate right now
so the
um so if I have time I'm going to
describe how how to implement different
equivalent models on particle systems
how to implement equivariant models on
images and and I have a few applications
one is a toy example that is easy to see
what's going on and then we have
applications to cosmology and to
vegetation
dynamics that I can
describe uh us yeah can I ask a question
yes so earlier you had mentioned that
there's this difference between these
active and passive
symmetries
um an an example for a physical system
would be where if I'm thinking about an
active symmetry uh how can I get
conservation of energy by implementing
the right set of symmetries in my
modeling or wherever so that energy is
conserved is that also part of the
consideration here yes so I'm going to I
have an example on the at the end of my
talk where we do that but the idea is
that if you if you know that your system
is
hamiltonian uh then you can uh you can
use something like a neural that does a
hamiltonian integration so then they
like the fact that there's there's a
constant hamiltonian is already embedded
in the model
so the energy conservation is part of
the definition of your of your model
okay okay thanks yeah I'll look forward
to that example later
yeah
so okay so how do you implement
symmetries okay the classical thing that
people do is do data augmentation uh but
I'm going to focus on like architectural
design which is like I'm going to
restrict the learning to the class of
functions that satisfy the St
and the way people do it is by using
weight sharing like for instance message
passing is a form of way sharing because
it's the same message that goes to to
every node the message function not the
same message but the same function then
there is a an approach based on
introducer representations that I'm
going to describe very briefly uh and
then I'm going to go into the idea of
using invariant theory for that so um so
the idea is so we have a group action
and maybe I I should have like a little
drawing like here so say um maybe I had
it before or not yeah here uh I think I
skipped this slide so the idea is that
you have a group that adds on a data set
and then if you if you apply the group
action to the input and then the output
doesn't change then you say that it's
invariant so for instance in this image
classification if you rotate the image
then the classifier doesn't change or
equ variant so for instance here I have
this particle system and I have I want
to predict the Dynamics so if I rotate
this particle system then the prediction
should rotate and the idea of equivalent
ml is that the hypothesis class satisfy
that for every choice of parameter so
for every Theta for every function in
your hypothesis class it satisfies the
symmetry so for every Theta F of G * X
is equal to G * f of x for instance here
so that's the idea so the question is
how do you implement a class of
functions that satisfy this property so
one way of doing that is by uh saying
okay I'm going to start with a field
forward neural network which is the
composition of linear functions and
nonlinear activation functions and then
I'm going to restrict the linear
functions so so that they satisfy the
symmetries and so there since there are
not that many linear functions that are
symmetric like say if you say like a
rotation invariant functions how many
linear functions are rotation invariant
not very many uh so so then what you do
in order to make the the space of
functions expressive is you extend these
two tensors so you say okay the linear
functions are not just going to take a
vector but they're going to take a
tensor of the input with itself K times
and they're going to Output a tensor
with the of the input with itself K
Prime times and so you want to look at
the functions that are linear and
equivalent here by just extending the
action to each of the orders of the
tensor and the question is how do you do
that and uh one person that that did a
lot of this work is Tess smid which I
think was working for you at some point
recently so she she developed many of
these methods and
and the the the thing that she does is
she uses representation Theory so the
idea is that how do you parameterize
these linear functions that are
equivalent in these tensor spaces and
basically they do this idea based on
group representations which basically
says that if you have an equivalent
map um then that is linear then you can
use some properties uh from like
representation theory that says that if
you take take your space and de compose
the space in the in the irreducible
components then this tensor space you
decompose it in the irreducible
components with respect to a group
action then a map is equivalent if and
only if it Maps a IR Ruble component of
the same type to Itself by a multiple of
the identity so the idea is they take
this space
uh the space the extensor space they
decompose the the input and the output
in the reducible components so they have
these elusive representations and then
from these elusive representations they
just read off what are the possible
parameterizations that send one space
into the next and that's a paper by
Thomas and Smith uh collaborators in
2018 and they have a very nice
implementation I think in t or
flow uh but but the hard part of this
approach is that in order to do this de
composition of this tensor product into
irreducible representations you need to
be able to compute the CL gon
coefficients which is is is known in
some cases but it's hard to do in
general so so yeah
so yeah so to summarize the idea is uh
to take a fi forward your network and
you replace the layer the linear layers
by linear equivalent layers on tensors
and then you use irreducible
representations to parameterize the
linear equivalent layers uh on these
tensor spaces that's the idea there's
another question of like how do you
choose the the activation functions and
that depends very uh it depends on the
group that you're using in some cases
it's easy but in some other cases it's
hard to to find no linear activation
functions that
work um so so that's that's the
irreducible representation approach uh
my my focus is different is a different
approach to the same problem which is
the imaran theory approach and I think
it's simpler but it it works in some for
some simple e groups that people using
classical physics but in general it's
not known what the invariant are so it
may be harder to do in
general um whereas the ru of
representation approach words in general
so the IDE is the following so we have
this uh this particle system over here
and the goal is to start just for
Simplicity so we have n particles in Rd
and our goal is to find all the
invariant functions that take these n
particles in Rd and outut a
scaler uh so we could look at the OD
which is or group or rotations which are
like OD is the rotations and Reflections
and then there's the Lawrence Group
which is uh is a similar group but it
has a different inner product and it
comes from uh special
relativity and the idea is that the
function that we want to parameterize
satisfies that if I rotate all my inputs
the function doesn't change because it's
an invariant function so in in order to
do that we can go back to the classical
um work in group Theory by vile that
shows that the first fundamental theorem
for invariant Theory says that a
function is O invariant if and only if
you can write it as a function of the
paway center products of your
inputs this is kind of intuitive right
so I have a point Cloud so I take the
paway in products of my inputs and then
I write a function on that so if I
rotate the point Cloud the paway in the
products of the inputs don't change so
the function that I write is going to be
invid with respect to
rotations or OD uh the the question that
we need to ask is like is that all does
that is that sufficient to write all the
functions that are in bing with respect
to rotations and the answer is yes and
there's many ways to see it but but
that's basically the idea
so that gives you a very simple way to
parameterize just the invariant function
so for instance if I want to learn the
energy of this particle system then I
can write it as a function that I learn
on the parway in products of the
positions and velocities of my of my of
my point cloud and that would be
invariant with respect to
rotations um so if I want to uh write uh
not just like the just a scalar function
but I want to write for instance predict
the Dynamics of this point Cloud what I
can do is I can parameterize learn it as
a as an equivalent function so say for
instance for each particle or for the
center of mass what I need to learn is a
function that takes these n vectors in
Rd so the point cloud and outputs a
vector in Rd that is equivalent with
respect to rotation so if I rotate the
input the output rotate and it's uh it's
not too hard to see that actually a
function is O equivalent if and only if
you can write it as a linear combination
of your input
vectors uh times uh a scalar invariant
function so a function of the inner
products that's in the previous case and
so this suggests a model for the
learning basically the model is you take
your input Point Cloud you compute the
scalers and then you learn different
functions um F1 or FN so like this this
uh coefficient functions and then your
output is going to be a linear
combination and you can implement this
in many ways you can implement it with
attention mechanisms for
instance
um um and this is part of something that
is can be seen in like a more general
theory that allows you to translate
Knowledge from invariance to
equivariance and then the idea is
basically that uh the equivalent
functions are the functions that satisfy
like that this commutative diagram over
here so say I have a a vector in B and
then if I apply the group
action here let's see if you see it uh
yeah I apply the group action then uh
and then I I apply the function is the
same as applying the function and then
applying the group in the output so you
can see it as a commutative
diagram
and and then uh just knowing that you
have a a group action in the in the
space V and a group action in the space
w induces an action on the space of maps
from B2 W so that the equivalent
functions are the fix points and and so
that suggests that the knowledge on the
invalent maps uh is sufficient to
transport that into knowledge on
equivalent Maps so all that I'm saying
and I'm not going to go into the details
of this is that this construction that I
showed you earlier on how to go from
like the invariant the the the
understanding of what invariant
functions are to what the equivalent
functions are is something that you can
do in general for other for other groups
as
well and so now I'm going to going to uh
tell you a little bit about this example
which is like a simple toy example but I
think that it explains how these models
can be implemented and and maybe other
more interesting we can discuss more
interesting problems where these can can
be used so in this example I have like
this double pendulum connected with
springs and so the problem is to predict
the Dynamics of this double pendulum and
so this this model this this this
problem has like a like an O2
equivalance so say if I do a rotation in
the XY plane then the Dynamics of the
pendulum rotates in the XY plane but
this model is not all3 equivalent or at
least
not in a prior because if I do a
rotation that moves the cais then the
the the model doesn't really uh doesn't
really behave in the same way because of
the because of how the gravity affects
the
Dynamics but if you if you move the
gravity Vector with the masses
everything at the same time then that is
O3 equivalent that this is kind of like
a coordinate transformation so we can
say that if you add the gravity Vector
as an input to your learning problem
then this is an o three equivalent
passive symmetry that you that you can
Implement and so you can learn the
position and momentums of your of your
particles as an O3 equivalent function
assuming that the gravity is an input to
your model and maybe the gravity is
fixed which is typically in life but but
still you you need to be able to compute
the invariance with the gravity as well
and so in this model this is a
hamiltonian system so this is this times
translation symmetry where like the the
hamiltonian kinetic energy plus
potential energy is conserved so if
you're going to learn uh if you're going
to use a um a machine learning model to
learn this you could say you can
implement the rotation symmetry these
all three and also you can implement the
Honan symmetry as well like the the and
then for that we have two approaches so
the classical neural oo approach which
is basically you learn a differential
equation you you you say my data
satisfies a differential equation that
I'm going to learn from data and so this
this there is the derivative of my state
with respect to time and this is an
equivalent function of my
input with respect to this uh o or in
this case o
O3 and and then we can learn that and
then we can use a OD integrator to do
the pr predictions and we can learn the
parameters of the differential equation
using that so that's one way to do it
and this would just learn an OD but we
can also use the fact that this
hamiltonian is conserved and so in order
to do that what we do is we are going to
use a hamiltonian un Network so we know
that the system is hamiltonian so
there's a
specific uh specific differential
equation that the data set F so I can
just make my model to learn a
hamiltonian h which is a scalar function
of my inputs and then use a hamiltonian
integrator to do the prediction of the
Dynamics and that incorporates all the
symmetries that we were discussing so I
think this is the answer to the question
that I got uh by TS just
earlier
but I I can comment more on this if you
want no that's okay that I understood it
thank you yeah so so the fact that you
use scalers gives you the O3 Symmetry
and the fact that you use a hamian
integrator gives you the uh the the
jonian Symmetry and then other works
like for instance there's works by
kanakis that uh Implement for instance
some simplec symmetry in machine
learning models by having specific forms
of integrator and a specific ways to
parameterize the
Dynamics um and so for and this example
this numerical example just shows you uh
here this like this is a like the
trajectory of the masses in face space
this these drawings and this table tells
you that the more symmetries you
implement the better the performance you
obtain so here we are obtaining like we
are implementing uh the O3 symmetries
with the neural o and the O3 symmetries
with the hamiltonian O and from here to
here you are uh you're adding one more
symmetry which is the time translation
Symmetry and then it works better and if
you go to the right this the the groups
that that you are using are or the
symmetries that you're imposing are
weaker and weaker and this model doesn't
impose any symmetrics so for a fixed
training set size uh the more symmetries
you implement the more constraint the
learning is and you can show there's
math results that tell you that the
generalization error is going to be
small just because you're constraining
to a class of functions that is smaller
and is consistent with the ground truth
solution uh so that is for uh the
symmetries with respect to uh rotations
and all but other symmetries uh they
have to do with um units are also useful
and interesting and for instance in this
case and just in this example what you
can do is you can see that you're
predicting this hamiltonian which is an
energy and has units kilogram met
squares divided by second squar so if I
do a transformation my training set so
that everything that had units of
kilograms now has units of pounds or
everything that had units of kilograms
now uh is multiplied by five then this
uh you know you you can predict how you
that would affect the output by just
doing dimensional analysis so that's a
scaling symmetry you can think of it as
the group of scalings acting on the
input um give you a precise known
scaling in the output assuming that all
the relevant inputs are uh in the model
and and if you do that then that is
another symmetry that you can
Implement into your model and one way to
do it is by using the backing hand pie
theorem that tells you that um that any
function that is units equivalent can be
written as a function of dimensionless
features so so the idea is you take your
inputs and then you can uh do some
transformations of your inputs so that
you can construct dimensionless features
so for instance I can take M like the M1
/ by M2 that's dimensionless and then
you can construct the basis of
dimensionist features and then you can
learn a function of your dimensionist
features and and that's give you a
dimensionless label and then you can use
a fix scaling to give you the actual
dimensional output and that's something
that people do in practice in many in in
many applications just working on like
the dimensional formulation of the
problem so for instance in pdes uh
people do that all all the time just
like write it write it in in a
dimensionless way so that the scaling is
correct
so
yeah so that's the idea and you can see
I mean I'm not going to go into the into
the details of the math but you can see
that this symmetry can be seen as as a
group like this consistence of the units
can be seen as a symmetry with respect
to a group action and the group is the
group of scalings uh that have to do
with the number of units that that you
have in the model in the models so here
would be like if you ever like things
can have units of kilogram met seconds
so the action is by uh
R
oops small it would be an action by like
R greater than zero to the three like
you can scale the masses you can scale
the distances and you can scale the
time and that's and then if you scale
that then it it affects the output by
scaling the masses linearly scaling the
distances uh quadratically and scaling
the times with like negative one2
-2 anyway so um
finally
um I'm going to discuss how can we
mathematically explain how much do you
gain by imposing symmetries and
so the idea is the following so if we
have
um if we have a learning problem
and
uh and you have like a task a regression
task then you can Define the risk of
like the expected value of the of the
error with respect to a ground
truth and and so the generalization Gap
is going to be the risk of your function
and so the generalization gap between
like a function f and the projection of
f onto the space of invar function
is going to be the risk of f minus the
risk of the projection of F and you can
see that under some assumptions I say
the group is Compact and the and the
measure that supports the data is
symmetric then you can actually quantify
that the risk the difference in the risk
is always non non negative and it's like
just the norm of the projection of f
onto the space of invalent functions so
that shows that you always gain
something by imposing symmetries in some
way uh because like the error that you
that you have is decreases by uh by
something that uh is uh how much you
throw out when you project on to the
space of Iman functions of course this
has a very uh strict hypothesis or like
assumptions and it requires that that
you can like understand like imposing
the symmetries is kind of like doing a
regression and then projecting onto the
space of invariant functions whereas in
practice people don't do that people
just like do a regression on a space of
invariant function so it doesn't really
match a projection but that this is just
one way of of explaining it
um so we have some uh applications to
cosmology basically the idea is that uh
um well David hog is my collaborator he
is um an astrophysicist and Kate is his
student and they work in cosmology and
basically what they have is like a a
very expensive um hydrodynamic
simulation and then they have a cheaper
dark m only simulation and so they want
to use the cheaper simulation to make
predictions of what happens in the in
the more expensive
simulations and and so what they do is
they write a machine learning model to
predict the properties of the galaxies
in the more expensive simulations by
defining the machine learning model to
be uh respecting this this symmetri so
they respecting units equivalence and
respecting rotation
equivalences as
well and they do that by representing
the the data in a way that has to do
with the scalers that we just described
before and they and they show that the
machine learning models that impose
these symmetries work better than the
ones that do not impose the
symmetries that's the idea and they they
write it in a way so that the models
that they obtain are
interpretable so uh another application
of this uh is the to vegetation Dynamics
um I'm not going to go into the details
of this application until unless you ask
me but basically the idea is that if you
have a a simulation of the vegetation
Dynamics the things that go into the
simulations have a lot of
units because include like the rainfall
and the water uptake and the vegetation
loss that Etc all of them have units and
so if you if you do it if you do a
regression that is units equivalent then
you can see that it will perform
better and uh
and let me just like show you a little
drawing of like how you can extend these
to images and the idea is that when you
work on images you have to use these
ideas of scalers or
uh vectors and tensors in in an image
setting so you can use like you can
extend the things that I that I told you
about uh using the scaler formulation
for implementing the equivariant
functions to an image setting where like
when you can do convolutions and you
combine this convolution idea with this
scalers idea and you can Define models
that satisfy the similar properties and
produce nice pictures
so as a summary and I I'm like maybe
five minutes over say that uh enforcing
exact symmetries in machine learning
give you the correct model assum of good
models assumptions better sample
complexity moralization error and we can
show uh how to uh parameterize certain
classes of functions that satisfy the
symmetries of classical physics uh using
basically uh I transformation notation
and and we can extend this to images and
that's it thank you for
your yeah your time thank you thank you
so much for U wonderful and informal
informative um presentation very nice
very nice um we're going to have a uh
question and an answer sessions we have
a 10
minutes maybe I can start with a one
philosophical question so you start with
a neural net model which is over
parameterized so you have a lot more
parameters to tweak to represent
something right so in some sense you
have a overdetermined system with a um
and you'd like to close that system by
introducing some sort of symmetry
constraints into your equations right um
so that you can uh generalize better um
what if well that works when you know
some system you're dealing with has
already you know some sort of symmetry
has to be there and you can impose that
right but what if you don't know the
system you're dealing with you don't you
don't know ahead of time what kind of
symmetry you have to
impose um is there way you can discover
that
symmetry yes that's a that's a great
question there there's a few papers
recent papers that try to learn the
images from data uh and they they do it
at different levels of uh success but I
think that it's yeah it's it's an
interesting question and it's it's not
fully solved I people try to
parameterize the symmetries in one
another way and then learn that from
data and then use that for for
predictions awesome okay so there are
works out there you want I can I can
point out some references there's a ref
like there's some work by the group of
um Andrew Wilson at NYU where they do
some learning of the symmetries on the
fly with so basically they they
parameterize the immes like
using like simple things like say well
my my symmetry needs to be implemented
as a matrix it should be local and then
they do like they basically parametrizes
in terms of the exponential map and then
they optimize jointly for the most
amount of symmetries and the smallest
loss for the training error and then
they just try to do that that way that's
that's one example there's also uh word
by Rose u in San Diego where they do
something similar as well
Rose you you
said okay so I know her okay great um so
let's uh move to the audiences um I see
Pat
um posted some questions in the chat
room he do you want to unmute yourself
and ask question directly
sure we can hear you yeah yep thank you
for your talk U so yes so you focused on
on neur of course the notion of
inductive bias is much more broader than
that and I'm and it's clear that
symmetries can play a role to me in with
many other different representations of
of learn knowledge so um I just want
like to understand how much of your
analysis is limited to neural Nets and
how much of it is more
General um so the this is more General
in the sense that that you don't need to
use neuronet you can use any form of
regression and impose the symmetries in
in that regression so for instance the
people that are doing the work in
cosmology are not using neur networks
they're just using simple models and
they're using their features so that
they satisfy the the symmetries of the
problem yeah so that's good great thank
you simple model as such as
what uh they are do doing
uh some form of like a lasso like a
linear regression with with SP
constraints yeah con yeah
okay all right um Pat that's it I had
another question about scale invariance
uh which okay yeah go ahead feels feels
very different for me but it but they
talk about is invariance and so I'm
curious as to whether there's any whe
whether that comes up here like scaling
Ence well I mean there's there's a
branch there are branches of science
that are who are very very focused on
systems that exhibit the same phenomena
at any scale and and and I'm want to
understand whether that's a different
use of the term invariance or whether it
is similar and there's a way to to model
it in the framework you proposed so for
instance would self similarity be one of
these properties is yes so
self-similarity could be phrased in in
this in this language actually there's a
book by Peter olver where they look at
the uh at self similarity in in
differential equations and uh how we can
uh look at it in the terms of of groups
invariances as
well okay thank you oh and yungu I just
wanted to mention the you is giving a
talk right like like in three minutes at
isi and uh oh show the link here yeah uh
you have to register and probably really
I'll I'll I'll send I I I will send a
link but you have to register um or you
might invite her to this to to the
seminar thank you all right if you I
I'll try and get the link and put it in
the chat box yeah that would be awesome
okay thank you
P awesome and other question I I don't
see any other questions in chat but um
you can ask um by unmute yourself and
then
yeah I guess I could ask a question
really quick um so part of the coming up
with the invariances is sort of doing
this projection to a set of parameters
which um are like in a sense the minimum
set that you need to describe the system
that takes into account all of the
symmetries and invariances right so like
in the double pendulum example you have
the S SO2
invariance is there any sort of
intuition behind what sort of projection
you choose to use as opposed to
something like an SVD or um so what we
do is once that we know what is the what
is the Symmetry uh then what we can do
is we can write the space of imaran
functions uh with respect to that
symmetry so for instance what is the SO2
imaran functions
and and so uh sometimes there's like
very like you can write as the invariant
functions are functions of these like
small features that you can construct
simply from the data so in the case of
say 03 then uh if you write any function
in terms of the scalars of the inner
products of your inputs then that
function is going to be invariant and
vice versa so that gives you like I
think that was where your question was
going right like yeah so what if more
complicated set of like like a
conservation law something like
conservation of energy yeah so if it's a
conservation of energy uh you're you
probably have you you probably have a
Honan right that you that you're
conserved that you have
conserved yeah and so what you can do is
you can write and and also you know that
it will satisfy a specific differential
equation so you can you can use the form
of the differential equation that it
will satisfy and then
learn the parameters that Define that
differential
equation and then you you just integrate
that differential
equation so it's basically you have a a
parameterization of the functions that
satisfy that property either via the
fact that they are um like the the the
scalars are are constant or via the fact
that there's a specific differential
equation that the data should satisfy
maybe you don't know what the parameters
are but if you know that if you satisfy
that specific differential equation then
you know that the energy is going to be
conserved okay all right
thanks um just really quickly um so a
lot of us are interested in embedding um
neural networks inside existing
scientific simulations in which case
we're interested in the networks not
only like representing the physical
quantities need to be conserved but also
numerical properties that won't lead to
exponential blowup and stuff like that
do you have any ideas on what kind of
symmetries we could employ to um
represent
that um so yeah that's a that's a tricky
question so for instance in the case of
this of the scaling invariance uh your
your invariance look like quotients of
things and that numerically blows up so
if you want to do like if you want if
you have that symmetry that has to do
with scalings in fact you can have like
very small scalings like you can work at
different scales and that's something
that is numerically unstable so you you
have to be uh careful with
that uh so you would I mean that that is
more of
a like how how do you do it in practice
so that it doesn't really blow up you
have to be careful so what we did was we
construct the invariant features and we
allow the invariant features to be
within a range and if if it it wasn't
within a range then we remove them since
the invariant features can be chosen so
that they are um um that you can have
more than the than redundant you can
have a redundant set of invariant
features you can remove some invariant
features that are ill conditioned and
get only use the ones that are well
conditioned and that's sufficient to
express the mod so in incorporating
redundancies and over
parameterization uh is uh is better than
doing something that that may not have
that property so you can you can remove
that ill conditioned Behavior by
incorporating redundant features does
does that answer your question um I
think so I'm more just I get nervous
anytime that I ined an OD in something
if I can't guarantee that it's on one
half of the complex graph MH yeah and
and I wouldn't wouldn't have a comment
uh about it unless it's like something
specific that I have done before you
know I think that it could many problems
like that may arise and I maybe I
haven't thought about
them sounds
good any other
question it's past two after
um maybe we it's a time to wrap up okay
okay let's let's thank our speaker today
uh for wonderful talk and wonderful Q&A
session I'm sure there are more
questions but I'm sure um you know so
that is going to be happy to get any
questions through email
right yeah yeah yeah of course yes yeah
all right yeah so thank you so much for
yeah for inviting me and I hope that
that was useful to you yeah yeah and I
hope that you know this event is
initiating some more collaboration
between Lawrence liore and your group at
John Hopkins so let's hope for that
thank you thank thank you that